here with reaction as florida senator
marco rubio is with us senator uh do you
see a correlation
between the rhetoric of say chuck
schumer he's on the steps of the supreme
court uh you know you'll be hit the
likes of which you've never been hit
before his his comments
do you see a correlation to the
animosity hostility and doxxing of these
justices
yeah i have a terrible feeling about
this sean i think this is headed in a
very dangerous direction i think the
last time i was on the show from this
very studio i said that at the time and
here's why this is a country 331 million
people okay you have people out there
basically saying that these members of
the supreme court are equivalent to the
ku klux klan to nazis you've had some
sort of saying burn the place down
331 million people it only takes a
couple of them to look at that and say
well if these people are that evil the
next step is to just take them out and
that's just the supreme court justices
uh not not to mention we've got hundreds
of members of congress that don't have
u.s marshals outside their home and you
know we want to thank the u.s marshals
for the role they played or we will be
having a very different day here today
in washington but this is an incredibly
serious thing this is not the only guy
in america with these thoughts in their
head and i have a very bad feeling about
the direction this goes on either side
i'm not in favor of this happening to
anybody i don't think i don't want
protesters showing them outside the
house of nancy pelosi or chuck schumer
anybody else i think there's a time
place and manner that for
free speech to be regulated you can say
whatever you want but there's got to be
some limits to it and in this particular
case it's illegal because these are
judges that these people are trying to
intimidate to make a decision that they
want in a court case
to me that's straight up harassment
intimidation
uh of these nine justices or in this
case the the six conservatives my
question is what about posting the
addresses or doxxing as they call it and
giving out the locations where or where
these people that serve in government
live uh isn't that inviting this
intimidation isn't that creating a
hostile work environment to use well
some of the favorite words of of woke
liberals
well there's only one reason for
protesters to show up
outside the home of a public figure and
that is to send them a clear message we
know where you live now maybe there's a
hundred people there and not a single
one of those hundred people are gonna
hurt anybody but i'm gonna tell you
someone's watching someone's taking that
now note on the internet where this
person lives and that one deranged
person is going to show up at the house
of someone and eventually harm them this
is an unfortunate trend that we're now
seeing it's a very very dangerous one we
should not be playing with this we are
playing with fire i'm not saying this
guy wouldn't have done this anyway if
he's truly as deranged as he appears to
be my point is that when you're
encouraging this when you're calling
your political opponents people that
have blood on their hands people that
are the same as the ku klux klan that
are coming to rip your rights from from
from you
you're going to have some people take
some pretty violent dramatic and
dangerous actions and that's what was
averted last night thank god
but i don't think we've seen the last of
this unfortunately all right so we're
going to have this big hollywood
presentation the january 6 committee
tomorrow night during this hour i think
some of it will still be going on um
what's fascinating to me is we've
actually gone back in time and in the
summer 2020 senator we have 574 official
riots we had dozens of dead americans we
had thousands of injured cops we had
billions of dollars in property damage
very few people were held accountable
even though we had video tape evidence
of people responsible for that
one why is there no committee for
looking into those instant instances and
two you know i look at the democrats
either they were silent especially the
ones on the committee they were either
silent about the summer or 2020 or they
lied and say they were mostly peaceful
when they were anything but peaceful
what does that tell you about their
feigned outrage that we'll see on
display tomorrow with their hollywood
from from day one i've said that if
people committed crimes on that day they
should be prosecuted and agree by jury
and so forth and that's what's happening
okay this is a hollywood paid political
advertisement they hired a producer to
put this thing on okay the criminal
justice system is already dealing with
it but here's what it says about it it
says that if you're a member of congress
and something terrible happens here on
the capitol grounds like what happened
on that day they're going to put a fence
up they won't do that for our country
but they'll put a fence up they still
have metal detectors in the house
chamber so members have to go to these
metal detectors they'll do all these
extraordinary things and mobilize the
national guard but you're if you're
among the hundreds of small businesses
that got burned to the ground the people
that were killed the people that were
harassed the people that suffer from
that well then we don't care about that
that well you know that we're going to
condone that we're going to excuse that
we're going to have a now vice president
raise money to bail people out of jail
now we're going to have prosecutors that
refuse to prosecute you and by the way
it doesn't matter if you would torch the
police car kill the security guard did
whatever you do that's not as big a deal
it doesn't matter as much and if you
call out the national guard or marshals
or anybody else that's nothing but the
gestapo that's their attitude it reveals
hypocrisy and the good news is people
see it for what it is that's why they're
getting it handed to them all over the
country and why i think you're going to
see that in november thank god as well
well thank god for that as well your
election is really crucial for the
republicans to keep control or get
control of the senate i want to ask you
specifically so
in the days leading up to january 6
there was a meeting with president trump
in the oval office there were four other
people there
chris miller the acting secretary of
defense cash patel is chief of staff
mark meadows was was there and
general milley chairman of the joint
chiefs was there
at that meeting for the people
that would be the president mark meadows
cash patel chris miller all told me on
the record that donald trump authorized
up to 20 000 troops to be used if in
fact they had problems on january 6th i
was able to get in in contact with
people
that
are around general milly and they
confirmed with for me today in a phone
call
that in fact issues involving security
in the days leading up to january 6
he did discuss with the president so the
question is
it once the president authorizes those
guard troops if they would have had ten
thousand or twenty thousand we wouldn't
talk about january sixth but the
president then the authority to call
them up once he authorizes that as
legally as required then it goes to
nancy pelosi and muriel bowser they
failed to call up those troops my
question is how do you blame donald
trump for that when it was their
responsibility to take advantage of the
resources he was offering them
well if this was a real congressional
hearing and not a kangaroo court and not
a circus and not a made for tv
production and an infomercial for their
political purposes those are the
questions they would be asking that's
exactly what they would be asking it
would be a review of why didn't capitol
police why didn't the sergeant-at-arms
take advantage of these resources that
were available that's what you would be
focused on but they're not going to be
focused on that this is a you know i
mean they moved this thing to prime time
they hired a producer to put it on this
is not a fact-finding mission this is a
two-hour free documentary sponsored by
virtually every major network in america
except for this one that's willing to
give it air time the only good thing
about it is most americans aren't going
to watch this garbage they i mean people
already know what happened that day
they're watching the justice it's not
even one opposing voice there's not even
one person that would have asked the
question of muriel bowser and nancy
pelosi you're right it's like a kangaroo
court uh senator uh we're watching your
re-election really closely thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else